when you choose something to cover it's
got to be a band you respect
and today you're going to do a cover of
a band that i love system of a down i
played their music called you know in
the 90s when i was at k rock and all
that [ __ ] that's a great band right
great band yeah we toured with them for
a summer and doing these festivals in
europe they were just they blew our mind
every night we were like well have you
ever performed aerials at a festival or
anything or is this the first time
we've never done ariel's at all i'm like
you know i'm here to just to just jam it
and see what happens i'm on again this
is great you guys have never performed
surgery's voice is so untouchable it's
like i'm just i'm just kind of here to
just jam and have some fun you asked for
a cover so we were like let's do this
guys this is a big moment
this is an important song system of a
down did this is aerials
[Music]
life is
[Music]
[Music]
always want to play but you never want
to lose
[Music]
then we turn is
[Music]
cause we are the ones who want to play
always wanna go but you never wanna stay
[Music]
we are the ones who want to chose
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] you got to do that in concert
that works